David is on the line in Colorado
hi David welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
how can we help hi thank you gentlemen
for taking my call
sure what's up so I don't know if you
guys are aware but Colorado just passed
or is going to pass a bill that puts a
lot of stipulations on law enforcement
and I work for a small agency and one of
those makes potentially makes the
officer personally liable up to $25,000
depending on how it plays out in a lot
of politics and all that stuff so I take
him to look at what is best for me and
my family to not put them in a bad
position
not that I'm doing anything wrong but I
still have to look at it that look at
the future which means what well major
the possibility is yeah would be that I
would have to walk away okay and so the
current environment with law enforcement
and with the legislators is going to
cause you to not want to be in law
enforcement anymore is that what you're
saying and that is what I'm saying okay
all right so what's your next next
chapter well I have a couple things that
I could potentially do one of them would
be being a subcontractor or a contractor
working for a family friend of mine who
runs vehicles basically trucking
vehicles from one location to the other
and I can make money doing that that
sounds like am left sounds like features
family stuff what kind of a career will
you go to now that your heart is broken
on the career you thought you had and
you're going to go another direction I
would ultimately like to run my own shop
rebuilding vehicles and doing restos and
custom custom stuff like that but I
don't currently have the capital to just
dive into that got it okay that sounds
kind of fun yeah I love turning wrenches
it's it's absolutely amazing yeah
especially on fun custom stuff and
high-end stuff
and things really tool something that's
a so that's a little boy's dream right
there man I'm with you okay I could
leave that I could love doing that so
cool all right so what Ken Coleman
always says is to you know get really
clear on where you want to go and they
start asking yourself you know what are
the steps I've got to take to get there
and so if the dream is five years from
now that you own a custom shop that has
a great reputation and a great cash flow
full of tools that are all paid for and
your income is higher than it is now and
you're happier then what are the steps
to get there right correct so yeah I
mean the biggest part would be you know
preparing and getting all the
information I need for that and tools
and luckily we me and my wife are debt
free that's beneficial good and it I
guess the hard part I'm having is is
walking away from something I've spent
so much of my time and effort into and I
just don't know how to convince myself
to do that right you know well I wish I
could help you with that I can't I I
mean I don't have an answer for a
political climate that is shifted
against your career the way it has I
don't I don't you don't embrace racism
Chris doesn't embrace racism I certainly
don't embrace racism but we also don't
embrace this idea that all police are
evil people and it should be all
punished and should all be treated like
second-class citizens so there's an in
you know it's it says if you have to be
one or the other and the logic is just
inconsistent but that is the environment
we live in where there's all this
hyperbole and drama mm-hmm and it's just
really sad because there's a lot of good
people in law enforcement are having the
exact same thoughts you're having and
the you know what are you going to run
all the good ones off and so you know
I'm with you my heart breaks for you
brother but I don't know how to tell you
to fix that and I can't really dispute
your lodge
I'm here David how long have you been in
law enforcement oh so I'm almost on
three years now and I actually worked
for a very small agency so I was blessed
to get a canine relatively early in my
career so I'm gonna canine officer for
about a year
okay and so you know relatively new and
as you said the career path just shifted
for you in your heart you know you
sitting down talking to your spouse
looking at this beginning to look at the
options that are open to you I
definitely would not encourage you to
make a knee-jerk reaction but to have a
coordinated plan but as Davis tapping
into looking at this and pursuing your
passion you're gonna be a happier
individual chasing money is fleeting and
it doesn't last long and I know you've
got a feed your family
but you want to be moving in that
direction as much so as this bill
actually passed in Colorado so it is
passed the house I am NOT a hundred
percent positive that the governor has
signed it but there is a pretty much no
question that he will sign it if he
hasn't already today okay all right so
it's pretty well a done deal
so basically the liability and personal
liability is put on a law enforcement
officer and what is your income so
salary is thirty seven thousand six
hundred fifty so we pay about thirty
seven thousand dollars on canine and
then you're supposed to accept liability
if someone doesn't like what you do up
to 25 thousand dollars and this is the
state of Colorado's best idea correct
there I'm stupid yeah it's sad and I
don't blame you it's wrong you know
racism is not right and cops misbehaving
it's not right and you know obviously
that's you know obviously you can't do
these things it's not obvious to
everybody apparently but it's obvious to
me it's obvious to people in my building
but the but that's just you know again
these are people government trying to
fix things with the wrong tool
as always reaching but I'm sorry man I
wish I could tell you that you were had
analyzed this improperly but if you were
my son I'd have to tell you that you're
for thirty seven thousand dollars a year
I'm not taking that risk yeah no not as
a family man right now how are you gonna
get people to be police officers in
Colorado you probably can't
unfortunately it's gonna be very
difficult or you're gonna get a lot of
young people that that you know are
unaware it's just a bad process and it's
not a solution Dave it's a grab in the
dark yeah and try and do something to
fix the broken parts but flailing around
generally breaks more than it fixes oh
so sad I'm sorry man I know your hearts
in this and the dog involved that you
love and it's just I breaks my heart for
you but and I'm not telling you you have
to do this you called me and said you
were doing it okay so you know we'll
support you whatever you decide to do
David that's for sure thank you for
calling this is the Dave Ramsey show